mindestens 140 forschungsprojekte
weltweit suchen derzeit intensiv nach
einem impfstoff gegen das corona virus
saß kopf 2 wird sogar noch in diesem
jahr ein impfstoff zugelassen fachleute
bremsen diese hoffnung jetzt denn eine
garantie auf einen impfstoff überhaupt
gegen coop 19 gibt es keineswegs doch
wie soll unser alltag dann weitergehen
klickst hans im future hier gibt's drei
mal pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen klick so gibt
es inzwischen übrigens auch für die
ohren und zwar als podcast die links zu
spotify und apple podcasts sind und in
der beschreibung
es ist das ziel von forschungsteams
weltweit die entwicklung eines
impfstoffes gegen das corona virus saß
kopf 2 nach meinung vieler fachleute
haben wir nämlich nur diese eine chance
um gegen die pandemie anzukommen erst
wenn es einen impfstoff gegen das virus
gibt können wir uns wieder ganz sicher
frei bewegen reisen arbeiten und partys
feiern daran ist jetzt aber noch lange
nicht zu denken
überall auf der erde leiden und sterben
menschen an der krankheit cupid 19
aktuell gehen die zahlen richtung einer
halben million tote und bei 10 millionen
infizierter treiber der zahlen sind vor
allem staaten wie die usa oder brasilien
wo der ernst der lage noch nicht erkannt
wurde
denn diese zahlen sind erst der anfang
und ich hatte es ja schon mal vor der
pandemie gesagt bei einem land wie
deutschland könnte ein ungebremster
verlauf eine million tote bedeuten und
in diesen ländern geht es wegen ihrem
halbherzigen vorgehen in diese richtung
in der vergangenheit konnte bei vielen
krankheiten mit hilfe von impfstoffen
ein solches desaster verhindert werden
zum beispiel gegen mumps pocken masern
oder die röteln
diese haben sehr sehr viele menschen
leben weltweit vor dem tod bewahrt eine
umfrage hatte anfang juni offenbart dass
sich jeder zweite deutsche 49 gegen das
corona virus impfen lassen würde wenn es
denn einen impfstoff gebe jeder vierte
26 prozent würde das in erwägung ziehen
und so dürften zahlreiche
forschungsinstitute und unternehmen an
schutzimpfung das muss man sich mal
vorstellen obwohl satz 2 seit etwa an
des jahres 2020 also erst seit diesem
zeitpunkt bekannt ist gab es nach
angaben der weltgesundheitsorganisation
who bereits anfang juni insgesamt 133
impfstoff projekte etwa 15 weitere sind
am start allerdings noch nicht
verzeichnet
mindestens acht forschungsprojekt
davonlaufen in deutschland und zehn
mögliche impfstoffkandidaten werden
bereits an menschen getestet hierbei
handelt es sich um freiwillige bei denen
getestet wird ob der impfstoff gut
vertragen wird welche nebenwirkungen
gibt es und welche dosis ist die
richtige in der fachsprache ist von der
klinischen erprobung die rede
nach angaben des verbands der
forschenden pharma unternehmen vfa
befinden sich derzeit bereits einige
projekte in phase zwei von insgesamt
drei im klartext bedeutet das dass der
mögliche impfstoff hinsichtlich der
verträglichkeit und wirksamkeit nicht
nur an tieren erprobt wurde
in der ersten klinischen phase wurde er
zudem auch bereits an einigen mensch und
zwar an bis zu 30 probanden probanden
erfolgreich getestet in der derzeit
laufenden phase zwei von drei wird der
entsprechenden wirkstoff dann schon an
einer größeren gruppe von menschen
erprobt es sind etwa 50 bis 500
freiwillige bei denen der mögliche
impfstoff nicht nur in sachen
verträglichkeit und dosierung getestet
wird auch die reaktion des immunsystems
wird analysiert und überwacht noch vor
einigen jahren hätte es nach der analyse
des virus bis zu einer zulassung des
impfstoffes üblicherweise bis zu 20
jahre gedauert dass es heutzutage und
speziell in diesem fall glücklicherweise
anders dafür sorgen neue technologien
und auch die erfahrung die
forschungsteams weltweit mit dem stoff
projekten gegen verwandte während
gesammelt haben sind jetzt gold wert und
so sind manche wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler optimistisch dass die
impfstoffentwicklung enorm schnell
vonstatten gehen kann
die weko hatte vor kurzem verkündet dass
sie mit einem impfstoff gegen das corona
virus bereits in 11 bis 17 monaten
rechnen andere experten experten sagen
voraus dass es bereits ende des
laufenden jahres einen impfstoff geben
könnte und tatsächlich einige projekte
waren bislang ziemlich erfolgreich zu
den großen hoffnungsträgern zählt unter
anderem der us-konzern moderner der mit
seinem mittel m rna 12 73 bereits mitte
märz mit der ersten phase der erprobung
an freiwilligen in den usa gestartet war
die testpersonen wo
kunden in den usa als helden gefeiert
nach unternehmensangaben verlief die
erste phase äußerst erfolgreich demnach
konnten bei den probandinnen und
probanden nach zwei impfung antikörper
nachgewiesen werden die mindestens so
hoch konzentriert waren wie bei
genesenden corona patienten die
freiwilligen waren demnach also nach
zwei impfungen immun gegen das koma wie
rosa skoff 2 auch in tierversuchen hatte
die impfung verhindert dass sich der
erreger in der lunge verbreitet konkret
hat der impfstoff das ziel die
menschlichen zellen umzuprogrammieren
diese sollen sich quasi in virus
fabriken umwandeln und corona virus
proteine produzieren allerdings
kontrolliert so wird im menschlichen
körper also eine infektion mit dem
neuartigen virus simuliert und das
immunsystem bekommt die chance einen
schutz dagegen aufzubauen ohne dass das
virus tatsächlich existiert das ganze
soll natürlich ohne schlimme
nebenwirkungen und ohne eine
tatsächliche krone infektion passieren
das us amerikanische unternehmen bekam
von us präsident donald trump mehr als
400 millionen dollar denn seine berater
hatten dieses im projekt als eines der
14 erfolg versprechendsten weltweit
ausgewählt das sogenannte operation top
speed soll bis ende des jahres 2020
einen zugelassenen impfstoff gegen coop
19 auf den markt bringen der name der
vom fiktiven warp antrieb aus raumschiff
enterprise abgeleitet ist ist jedenfalls
programm
obwohl die zulassung noch lange nicht in
reichweite ist soll noch in diesem monat
mit der produktion des impfstoffes
begonnen werden falls das projekt
scheitert also der impfstoff dann nicht
funktioniert in den test muss eine ganze
charge wieder vernichtet werden zunächst
steht für das biotech-unternehmen
moderne allerdings eben noch phase zwei
und drei jahren auch hier muss sich der
impfstoff erst mal als wirksam und
sicher beweisen und genau das ist die
große herausforderung denn die
klinischen tests der phase 3 bei der
hunderte bis tausende menschen den
impfstoff in der fachsprache vakanz
ihnen verabreicht bekommen ist nicht nur
langwierig sondern auch entscheidend
erst hier macht sich beispielsweise das
anti wheelie pendent enhancement kurz
a.de bemerkbar
hierbei handelt es sich um ein sehr
seltenes phänomen das zum ersten mal
beim dengue-fieber virus beobachtet
wurde
die rede ist
von infektions verstärkenden antikörpern
die bei einer zweitinfektion mit dem
gleichen oder ähnlichen subtyp des virus
zu einem schweren krankheitsverlauf
führen und genau das lässt virologin und
virologen skeptisch sein denn auch bei
coronaviren kann dieses seltene phänomen
der sogenannten infektions verstärkenden
antikörper auftreten
erst wenn das also durch die phase 3
ausgeschlossen wird sind die zuständigen
behörden dazu in der lage einen
impfstoff zuzulassen europa ist es die
europäische arzneimittelagentur ema und
in den usa ist es die food and drug
administration
doch nicht nur in den usa sondern auch
in großbritannien ist die erste
testphase an freiwilligen angelaufen
etwa 1000 patientinnen und patienten
sollen nun mit der phase 3 staaten
ebenso wie eine testreihe mit kindern
beteiligt ist die oxford university die
an einem sogenannten vector viren im
stoff forscht ein impfstoff der im fall
von corona über ein harmloses virus den
bauplan eines proteins in den körper
schleust das saas kopf zwei zum
eindringen benötigt der körper soll so
antikörper dagegen bilden saß kommt 2
hätte dann keine chance mehr
bereits im september könnte das
vereinigte königreich mit dem impfstoff
beliefert werden der kölner virologe
florian klein fasst das so zusammen so
schnell wie bei saas kopf 2 war der
medizinische und wissenschaftliche
fortschritt noch nie der druck schnell
ans ziel zu kommen ist jedenfalls enorm
hoch und der druck an die forschung
ebenfalls um genau das sehen manche
fachleute skeptisch dazu carlos nuzman
vom helmholtz institut in braunschweig
das ist das wovor ich angst habe dass so
viel druck ausgeübt wird das unreife
vakzine auf den markt kommen ein mensch
der krank ist ist gewillt gewisse
nebenwirkungen in kauf zu nehmen um
geheilt zu werden aber eine impfung
verabreicht man einen gesunden es darf
nur eine vakzine zugelassen werden bei
der sichergestellt ist dass der nutzen
für den geimpften überwiegt fest steht
jedenfalls es ist ein wahnsinniger
wettlauf gegen die zeit und die jagd
nach dem impfstoff verläuft
kompromisslos wer hat zuerst an
wirksamen impfstoff entwickelt der ohne
nebenwirkung einen zuverlässigen schutz
von corona bietet der virologe christian
drosten hatte dazu in einem interview
mit der zeit gewarnt es ist denkbar dass
die situation
so schlimm wird das regularien außer
kraft gesetzt werden man könnte sich
vorstellen dass man bestimmte aspekte
der impfstoff zulassung für diese krise
übergeht und dass man nicht gut
ausprobierte impfstoffe verimpft also
vorsicht ist geboten hier müssen die
zulassungsbehörden dagegen steuern sie
dürfen nicht auf die uhr gucken sondern
müssen studien sicht nun analysieren wie
sicher und effektiv die
impfstoffkandidaten wirklich sind bisher
liegt der rekord für die schnellste
entwicklung bis zur zulassung eines
impfstoffes bei vier jahren hier ging es
um den impfstoff gegen mumps doch
bislang kann niemand sicher sagen dass
die impfstoffentwicklung bei dem neuen
corona wir es genauso schnell oder sogar
noch schneller vonstattengehen kann
möglicherweise nimmt das ganze auch
jahrzehnte in anspruch und mit letzter
sicherheit ist es überhaupt nicht mal
klar dass es überhaupt mal einen
sicheren und wirksamen impfstoff geben
wird das sagt beispielsweise der
münchner virologe oliver keppler in
einem interview mit tagesschau.de wir
müssen uns an den erfolgen aber eben
auch an den misserfolgen der letzten 30
jahre messen lassen
wenn wir zurückblicken auf die
impfstoffentwicklung gegen anderen
pandemische infektionskrankheiten durch
viren bakterien oder parasiten wie
hiv/aids dengue-fieber tuberkulose oder
malaria
das sind geißeln der menschheit die seit
jahrzehnten für leid und tod sorgen und
wir haben es bisher nicht geschafft auch
nur gegen einen dieser vier einen
effektiven impfstoff zu entwickeln
es gibt also tatsächlich einige
krankheitserreger an denen sich die
forschung die zähne ausbeißt bereits 184
wurde das hi virus identifiziert und
trotz vieler anläufe sind alle impfstoff
projekte gescheitert auch gegen
hepatitis c konnte bislang keinen
impfstoff entwickelt werden um bis zu
zwei millionen menschen weltweit
infizieren sich weiterhin und das pro
jahr an malaria sterben jährlich etwa
eine million menschen und auch hier gibt
es keinen zugelassenen impfstoff und das
obwohl seit jahrzehnten danach gesucht
wird dennoch ist auch hier klar dass es
bislang niemals solche gemeinsamen
großen anstrengungen gab einen impfstoff
zu entwickeln zahlreiche unternehmen und
forschungsinstitute sind dabei und es
fließen milliarden euro doch klar ist
auch setzt das ist keine garantie dass
wir es schaffen einen super impfstoff zu
entwickeln
denn die anforderungen sind hoch der
impfstoff soll zum 1
sehr effektiv sein er soll im besten
falle alle menschen die games werden vor
einer infektion mit dem neuen corona
virus schützen
doch nicht nur das denn natürlich spielt
auch die sicherheit eine entscheidende
rolle
auch für ältere und sehr kleine kinder
soll er sicher sein und keine schweren
nebenwirkungen zur folge haben und zum
dritten wäre es natürlich wünschenswert
wenn innerhalb von kürzester zeit
milliarden impfdosen hergestellt werden
könnten dazu der virologe oliver keppler
im tagesschau de-interview
die hoffnung auf einen solchen super
impfstoff zu setzen ist aus meiner sicht
völlig überzogen das könnte auch sein
dass wir den nie haben werden wir müssen
stattdessen darüber sprechen ob wir teil
erfolge erzielen könnten
der wissenschaftler meint damit
beispielsweise die entwicklung von
impfstoffen die zumindest bei bestimmten
personengruppen für eine teilimmunität
sorgen möglicherweise könnten dann die
schweren infektionen wegfallen und
manche menschen gut geschützt sein er
appelliert neben der
impfstoffentwicklung auch effektive
antivirale medikamente weiter nach vorne
zu bringen auch der immunologe ian
frazer aus australien bremst die großen
erwartungen er sagte in einem interview
mit dem tv sender seven news wir müssen
auch erkennen dass es nicht immer
möglich ist einen impfstoff zu bekommen
nur weil wir an wollen eine ähnliche
meinung hat auch david nabarro
sondergesandter der
weltgesundheitsorganisation für coop 19
wir können nicht verlässlich davon
ausgehen dass überhaupt ein impfstoff
gefunden wird oder wenn er entdeckt wird
ob er alle tests auf wirksamkeit und
sicherheit bestehen wird
doch wie sähe dann unser alltag aus ein
leben mit dem corona wie es auf
absehbare zeit ist diese welt dann eine
andere und wir müssen uns weiter mit
bestimmten verhaltensregeln abfinden und
konsequent anwenden abstand halten und
nase bedeckung tragen und
hygienemaßnahmen einhalten bis es
effektive impfstoff oder aber
behandlungen gibt wird das alles zu
unserem leben dazu gehören ob es uns
gefällt oder nicht und klar ist auch
alle anstrengungen werden wohl nicht
umsonst sein denn selbst wenn sich die
pandemie von selbst abschwächt und wir
die zweite welle nicht erleben sind die
bisher entwickelten konzepte weiterhin
äußerst wertvoll denn saß cause 2 wird
nicht das letzte corona virus sein das
vom tierreich auf den menschen über geht
dann könnte man aber beim nächsten mal
möglicherweise schneller reagieren
schaut man in die vergangenheit zurück
sind während der impfstoffentwicklung
einige erreger seltener geworden so
beispielsweise beim ebola ausbruch von
2014 15
in westafrika der impfstoffkandidat rvc
buff war gerade fertig als die epidemie
plötzlich verebbte
doch jetzt wird auch dieses virus wieder
in der republik kongo und es gab dort
erst anfang juni wieder einen neuen
ausbruch wir machen uns mit unserem
verhalten indem wir immer näher an
unberührte biotope heranrücken sie
ausplündern und ihre tiere verwerten und
damit solche tödlichen wären geradezu
einladen extrem angreifer für solche
krankheiten wenn wir unser verhalten
nicht ändern werden wir wohl auf dauer
mit diesem tödlichen begleiter leben
müssen dann hätte jetzt ein zeitalter
der masken und des abstands begonnen
corona virus hilft trennende silvia
anklicken hier anschauen und abonnieren
und zwar einfach medizin es gibt glaube
ich keinen kanal auf dem man mehr über
cupid 19 erfährt als bei einfacher
medizin also abonniert pflicht und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran